[Music]  he's gonna do a speech  see what's happening here  you're afraid  oh no  anxious  my friends  times like this we need to unite come  together  i'm sorry me it's very hard to get a  rousing speech with the hate noise  oh god we're gonna die  so  this is my vow  oh god she will die  that seems a bit dangerous  this ends here and now  [Applause]  marvel studios thor love and thunder  pg-13 tickets on sale now how exciting  [Music]  experience it only in theaters july 8th  there's a maniac who seeks to end us all  we must do something  i'm putting together the greatest team  ever called he's my best friend valkyrie  we get to fight again  the guardians give me those and jane the  old ex-girlfriend judy foster jane  foster  you are not like the other gods of kiln  tickets on sale now  [Music]  you